let's let's talk about this weird story
because just i don't know whatever oh
yeah lme forced to halt nickel trading
cancel deals after prices top 100
thousand dollars yeah hoard your nickels
because they're 25 nickel
the london metal exchange forced to halt
nickel trading the lme's shock move came
as western sanctions threatened supply
metal exchange russia produces the uh
nickel i guess in the 1990s a rogue
sumitomo trader tried to corner the
copper market and tin trading was
stopped for five years in the 80s
so uh right now
i i with the price of nickel being as
high as do they say the actual number
here we go uh 2 250
a ton of nickels do the math on the
nickels you have in your piggy bank
they're 25 percent nickel wow got a lot
of money yeah says they're 17 a pound
nickel whoa
so divide 17 by four into a pound of
nickels
maybe you'll have more money i don't
know maybe not but the copper in a
nickel is already worth more yeah but
more importantly they need them for
electric they've got batteries right
right right so a nickel's got to be
worth 10 cents right now right
might be but it's illegal to do anything
about that right yeah why does why do
you think because canada got rid of the
penny
when did canada get rid of the penny
five years ago yeah it's still crazy to
me that there's pennies in america yeah
yeah it is weird with the
nothing well i know but there must be i
don't know it makes no sense a good job
how much money pennies is there yeah but
you know here here's the issue you could
probably find a way to scheme
money by using the um
using rounding up and rounding down and
i i legit well that's what they do i
legitimately mean this so no no that's
so
in office space you're referring to so
in uh basically yeah yeah like if you go
to a store and you buy something and
it's like 124 you save the four cents
then you sell it for 125 you get an
extra dime on top right but no rounds
out running up to 125. and 120.2 would
be 120. 124 rounds at 125. yeah okay
but i'll tell you this but that rounding
is done
like you know which way if it comes to
122 you you win sometimes you lose
sometimes yeah what i'm saying you could
plan it you could so you could do a deal
with a company where you're like i'm
gonna buy at 122 and save two cents
you're not gonna send you're only gonna
save two cents per order you have to buy
each one individually like what like
let's say
see what yeah you go i'm gonna buy ten
thousand things it's like yeah and you
save two that'll be the best negotiation
they go yeah that's not how that works
build an automated system yeah and you
can you can
office space it yeah literally kind of
david
but
you but also people can tell like for
example if you if you add the products
together with the prices do the thing
and you go but my system uh rounds it
down when it should have rounded up it's
like well then by that logic yeah i
could also just change the price to you
know scam an extra buck from people
without lying that's true like at that
point you're just stealing from people
so so you're saying banned a penny yeah
i think
they're rid of the penny but then what
happened to all the pennies everybody's
got well i don't know that's what canada
did with them yeah i don't know um yeah
i think they have them all though they
have them all at penny gumball machines
yeah
i don't know the only real people who
would lose out is those penny flattening
machines yeah yeah whoever runs those
businesses would be now no i i've seen
some of those now that you know for
those aren't familiar you put a penny
and then 50 cents and you crank it yeah
now you just put 50 cents in and it drop
a token comes down and you crank it it
smashes the token oh i did some math
you'd need
1440 nickels to get four dollars worth
of nickels in in nickel okay if you want
to melt down and get a 25 i don't know
what that means fourteen hundred and
forty nickels to get about four dollars
and fifty cent worth of next what's that
five dollars but hold on let's do that
do the nickelodeon do the nickel and the
copper any piece of paper and then do it
by like hundred nickels you know what i
mean like no 100 nickels that's so
that's you know uh
you've got seven seven 75 percent of
that is copper 25 percent of that is
nickel
so how much does a nickel weigh
you know how much and
yeah you have 91 nickels in a pound
91 and that's that's a fourth of a pound
of nickel
so you'd have 360 300 i didn't know this
was going to be on the test i know yeah
i wasn't ready for this i didn't i
didn't think we were going to talk about
metal prices
danny came in he was like let's talk
about the london metal exchange the
price of nicholas has gone up recently
and there's a lot on crazy effects of
this war it's true yeah crypto solves
this conversation ever happening again
yeah there's no pennies in crypto
there's just a fraction of a fraction of
a fraction of a fraction of a penny yeah
that's better
yeah but look at it this way if if the
small if a satoshi the smallest um
the smallest form of a bitcoin or
fraction
was worth one cent one bitcoin would be
a million dollars yeah so
that's what i'm saying and then the
future people are like we need to get
rid of these stupid satoshis
nobody uses them for anything but but
they're not but you would because it
would just be like that's three thousand
satoshi's you know yeah yeah yeah just
be on a ledger and then everyone's gonna
i think bitcoin is the currency of the
future
i think uh the the world economic forum
type people they love it and uh i'll
tell you this too you see that they just
yeah we were just talking about it but
you know but i went to davos in i think
it was 2017 maybe it was 2017. and the
whole thing was crypto like the whole
event like obviously the world cup
economic forum itself which is security
and like high profile we're talking
about a lot of things but the peripheral
events they do because people what
happens is when the powerful elites meet
roaches you know like right now yeah are
they are they meeting yeah in this room
no it was i think it's a yes us no more
diabolical we're talking about getting
rid of the penny
this is how it happens behind closed
doors
when you have like a thousand
millionaires and billionaires all
meeting at this privileged event then
you get a whole bunch of people worth a
couple hundred k trying to push their
businesses who show up at the base of
the mountain like they're in the
mountains yeah and then they they put on
events but they're they're connected
their friends their family they're just
not as high up
and so when i went there the whole thing
like almost every business was like
pitching crypto and there was the future
they were like government officials and
family members i was meeting like i was
meeting like presidential families and
they were like bitcoins the future i'm
telling you and i've been telling people
i'm like i think i think the world
economic forum davos elites the global
elites they want bitcoin to take over
now joe biden has just instructed you
know they're saying you have to
investigate a digital dollar or whatever
so there you go it's coming yeah i've
either uh it's there's a there's half
there's one where it's they wanted and
then there's the other version where you
know you realize you can't compete with
it and this is happening whether you
control it or not
right
yeah i think so some people have said
can't beat them join them situation
can't beat them join them and then take
it over but but if they're if they do a
digital dollar they tokenize it it's
going to have to be on what the ethereum
network or they have to make their own
version of ethereum i don't think they
can make their own blockchain yeah
the idea is to make their own blockchain
and i mean or essentially nationalize
the blockchain or have no blockchain
which is even scarier it's just another
ledger that they control and have well
isn't that essentially just the bank at
this point right yeah so so something
interesting happened i we had to buy a
vehicle for uh for the company to pull
the rvs we got it we got a ram truck
and i bought it through a bank and
uh they don't let you come in and buy it
outright many of these places so you
have to finance and they said but if you
finance it you can literally pay off the
bill tomorrow and there's no fees or
anything like that you just it's done
but we won't do it personally why
because they don't want to take the risk
if i say like here's a check for 50
grand they're going to be like and then
what happens if it bounces we don't want
to deal with that have the bank pay it
and then you pay the bank back have the
bank take the risk okay so this is what
we do right
and then like two days later when i get
the bill like i get the notification for
online i pay the whole thing off and
then two or three months later i get a
phone call from this bank and i ignore
it cause i'm like i got no business with
them another day goes by i get a phone
call that goes by and then finally i get
a voicemail and i check it and they're
threatening to repo the truck which i
own outright and paid for in full and
when you go through they they lost the
transfer they lost the transaction so i
called they were like we don't have any
transactions from you like you owe us
the full amount and i was like i went to
my bank and i did everything i was like
i went to your website i failed at
everything as you expect me to fill that
fill out my bank debited the cash and so
i called my bank and they were like
money's gone and then i was like where
did the money go and they're like
sir do you know how banking works
and i was just like
yes and they're like right on our end we
wrote in our ledger the money is gone
and this account now has the money which
means they now have to deal with it
because we've subtracted it from your
account so like the money's just gone
it's like it's gone and then i called
the other bank and they were like we
have no record and we have not updated
your account i'd be going postal right
now if this is me blind scammed me out
of a thousand dollars and i was i was
ready to burn the place to the ground i
was so mad well so i tweeted at him and
then everything got better it's funny
how this how the hell yeah
you have this these days but that that
is so messed up that would you tweet at
them
they stole my money my bank i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna say it here like
because you already did i thought i
didn't say the name of the bank okay but
it was it's a large bank and uh
they said did you tell them like listen
by the way the tweets and the tweets
about the start this is your first
warning i was like
i'm going to tweet so help me and they
were available to you and then they were
just like tweet ahead sir tweet go ahead
and tweet sir what are you gonna do
about it and then i went to my million
followers on twitter i was like this
bank is stupid and they call me back
like i am so sorry oh
i told blink fitness i was about to
tweet and they said
they
fix it
they said we saw it we we didn't care
about we didn't the tweet didn't matter
but we did see the pythons and the
photos yeah and we don't want to be
messing with those yeah but here let me
let me let me clarify like in all for
all in all seriousness i did tell them
on the phone i'm like guys i went on
your website i sent you this money my
bank took it from me it's not here
stealing from it you lost it you figure
it out and they were like no we won't
and then i said then my only recourse is
what to sue you okay here's what i'm
going to do i'm going to tweet about it
i'm going to talk about it excuse me my
name is and they said fine by all means
we i think we did mention it briefly i
tweeted about it and then also i get
emails saying like oh we're so sorry
about this problem we're gonna rectify
it for you and then uh what ended up
happening was
i i pulled up the information from my
bank and sent them like i don't want to
do this i'm like why am i sending you my
statement yeah i don't want to do a
bunch of work because it's not that it's
like i don't want to send strangers my
bank account information it's got more
than just that one transaction but you
know what we're doing business i've got
a bunch of other transactions and people
expect privacy so what am i gonna do i'm
gonna just screen grab the one bar
saying the money went through and
they're like yeah i'm like okay fine but
anyway i'll tell you this here's what
really bothers me about our modern
society is that
yes my friends i can tweet and these
companies bend over backwards for me you
can yeah right that's screwed up yeah i
was flying on american airlines once
jordan peterson was getting mad at
microsoft the other day yeah and then
and it works
i flew up for him i flew on american
airlines there was a storm we didn't
know what was going on we landed in
texas everybody was delayed i tweeted
what's going on with this and i
immediately get a message like we're
gonna take care of you skip the counter
go right to this guy and they were like
we got you booked already and then i'm
watching like you know 500 people
waiting in line all angry their flights
are delayed
but this is a problem because it's
creating this i i don't like the
classism the elitism
where if you if this is why you get
virtual signaling you get the influencer
deal people know that if they have
followers they can bully people with
influence stakeholder capitalism that's
right and it's creepy it shouldn't be
that way
it is a little creepy where i go okay
i'm getting screwed over by this you
know car company or gym or whatever in
my case blink fitness uh
did you resolve it by tweeting that i'm
currently resolving it on the gym caster
yeah
[Laughter]
see those swords in the background
as much as i hate the empire or dislike
being it the fdic insurance is like if
you're if your bank account screws you
if your bank screws you you can get it
the money back but once that's gone if
that's not there it's it's right it's
worse than that because that was what
everyone says with these things they go
yeah just get the money back but what
they do is they have your account on
pause for a year or two years instead of
canceling when you try to cancel then
they open it up two years later and just
start charging you then because
uh blink fitness is the name uh and
because of that
most people's credit cards have changed
a couple years or at least you know
whatever percentage if you change every
six years and thirty percent of people
would every two years would have a new
credit card so you can't call your bank
because they just have you owe us money
and it didn't go through the only and
then they go it's going to collections
so you can't call your bank because it
didn't they can't even disrespect you
why don't you send them an invoice
send them an invoice for what
do the same thing back
well i can't i can't send it to
collections yeah you can
i see what you're saying you literally
could but wouldn't collections go i go
the bank owes me six hundred dollars
imagine collection goes yeah yeah i go
for a lot didn't you ever hear the story
there was there was a dude i can't
remember i can't remember exactly it
seems like a lot of work this dude had a
thing happen where the bank
accidentally um filed like a claim
against his house
when he had paid it off and so he sued
them back and won like 1200 bucks and
they refused to pay it
he showed up with the sheriff and they
went inside and started taking the bank
stuff that's so funny but but love it
i mean look i'll i'll be honest it is
really hard to to use the systems the
way the corporations like
possible it's not impossible and you
know what else is but it's hard it's
hard and it has to essentially be a
passion project because you're going to
spend a week of your life to save a few
hundred bucks most of the time depending
on how you have it it legitimately has
to be your hobby yeah well you got super
screwed because of the whole wrong
credit card because normally i just said
to you i know just call you part of
their business model it's two years
later but the point remains it is true
the only way to get your uh
anything done is to you know how exert
influence because they so as soon as
that happens you go okay so you are able
to deal with i don't know why you why
didn't you go laura loomer style and
just go outside of blink headquarters
literally just said which boys just
yesterday i was bored and dude i
actually still might cuff yourself to
the equinox dude that would be really
funny that first off they'll be the
opposite of this guy if i handcuffed
myself to the to the
stair master guys got himself handcuffed
to the donut trick
i'm not leaving till i get my money back
yeah i'm at the dunkin donuts i ain't
leaving until you give me another
chocolate duster no that'd be funny if
you showed up at the blink fitness like
a sandwich board and you're like you're
protesting that'd be pretty funny give
me my money well that's the thing where
it's always you know you all you can do
is go in and sort of yell at the
employees that have nothing to do with
the scam you know no i'll say the blink
fitness they're not they're right on it
they're getting the taste of that
they're not helpful
they're getting a taste i think you made
a good point out like social pressure is
is the way or one of the ways and that's
what like antifa's been doing and blm's
been doing to get things canceled but it
is like power power no truth but power
if you can get the mob to get behind you
the corporation will back obviously a
lot of these places yeah there's a lot
of places you know the blogosphere as
essentially to some degree their
influence is worth a lot less than it
used to be so they've devalued all their
tools you've not gotten your money back
from blank fitness
no i it's the case is closed i paid it
and it's over but they but you're saying
that and i basically said and they were
like blah blah blah sorry and i go well
no you stole 500 to me and i'm not happy
about it so they they
they stole 500 bucks from you yeah
something like that so like probably so
if if you know i don't know hundreds
twice by the way this this is i don't
even need to get in the nitty-gritty but
they did the same scam to me twice so
they paid it off in case i mean there is
a saying and they call immoral to let a
sucker keep his money right so so
if of people uh
you know who maybe listen to a podcast
you want to message me and do a class
actually reach out oh just sent an email
saying blink fitness you took this guy's
money you blink in your money's guns
yeah i mean if you go look at the yelp
reviews of blink fitness every single
one of the reviews is what ryan is
saying yeah nobody's like great gym it's
all they scammed me out of my money give
me my money back like fitness where's my
oh yeah i lost uh i lost a pound the
first day how'd that happen they took my
wallet so it was that you signed up you
quit but in the contract it says we're
going to it's a they're going to start
your account back up in two years or no
because of covid because of covin i
basically they put it on hold and then
they go okay you have to if you want to
work out you have to come wear a mask
and you got to do a certain time like
okay just leave it on hold they go we
can't and i go okay just cancel it and
then they go fine so they go oh and then
it's three months later i just start
getting charges again and i go oh they
go i thought you canceled they go no we
didn't cancel it uh we just put it on
hold and now you always i go just cancel
it down they go well unless you pay this
five hundred dollars we can't cancel oh
wow and to cancel it you have to send in
a letter to their corporate officer you
can't go into the location that you
signed because i was going to the same
blink fitness system you can't go in
there and say hey i'd like to cancel
they go okay uh here's an address
send a letter to this address requesting
cancellation if they want it to cancel
they basically you're like you need to
do you know we're going to give you
three challenges yeah yeah seriously i
want to cancel this account they go you
have to climb this mountain in under
four minutes there's like a they're like
just go through that door in the back
and you go through it it's like this
like lush elven paradise and there's a
bridge and try to cross it and the troll
comes out yeah
riddles
you've gotta cast the ring into the
fight and you go and your uh receipt for
cancellation is in one of these nine
boxes
you must cast your membership cards into
the fires of mount doom if you open the
wrong door it's you just bought four
more years like this is probably
triggering so many of your listeners who
have gone through this exact same thing
buried this in the back of their mind
and now this is coming back well this is
how gyms make money though yeah you know
gyms
they they they know everybody everybody
signs up guys named jim make money
working his mechanics how why gyms how
come it's always just let's do this
on january 1st everybody's like i'm
going to show up and i'm going to get
fit and so these gyms in the first week
of january get massive sign-ups and they
can scam them for the next couple years
right because they know no one's going
to come back
and so they're just like they tell you
because i signed up for a gym and it was
in like february or something like four
or five years ago and i still pay them
to this day yeah well because there's
like cancelling is admitting defeat as
well like you're essentially saying i
give up when you cancel so so many
people do that and then they're like
well i you know i might go but what what
they tell you
when you're signing up they say to you
like this is a two-year term they force
you to be a long-term hoedler of their
gym membership yeah but um i i think
like i don't mind having a specific gym
membership because you never know if you
need to use a shower that's a
that's definitely 100 like battered wife
syndrome you go no it's fine that i pay
300 bucks a year maybe one day i'll need
a shower
because you could just go in and pay to
go to the show when you're traveling
around the country several years ago
when i'm on like one it was one and a
half flights like two flights every
every three weeks like i would fly
and you don't know exactly where you're
gonna be i've popped into one of these
gyms and i've been like right on you
know well the trick is to pop in without
your membership and act like oh what the
hell i mean that's the hack very
confused all the van people all the
people who live in brands the the kind
of nomads that's their deals you you get
a
gym membership yeah you sleep in walmart
parking lots yeah that's the future
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
yeah i had a friend did that he was like
a camper kind of guy he loved it
but then but then he needed to meet a
woman and he's like i gotta go get a
house yeah yeah but what if you get like
what if you get like a full-size house
but you know with wheels
so it's not a van it's literally a house
you can drive yeah mobile home they
believe they call those
yeah yeah but like a real camper home
that's my mom we were talking about the
homes where they're like you ever see
them relocating an actual house that's
cool and they're like driving at like 10
miles an hour yeah and there's a porch
and everything yeah like a whole house
you know what we should do we should we
should build something that can like
fold out into a house
so it's like it can be driven on the
back of like a 16-wheeler like you know
like yeah
i believe you're excited i'm so driving
a tent no i you know like with walls and
like power outlets
you ever see those houses where they
they 3d print it they're like
yeah that's cool we're getting close to
the right materials the meta materials
that are super thin super lightweight
super strong structurally well well look
nickel something like nickel yeah let's
let's we're gonna build this house with
nickel copper nickel bitcoin and russian
bones right well there's
you know once you make enough money you
do two things you replace all of the
electrical work in your house with
silver and graphene
because you know because why not spend
three million dollars on the electrical
system and then it's a good investment
yeah because then no one knows and when
the apocalypse happens you just punch
your wall and pull the silver out and
boom how you get you're out we're out of
here yes right
rip it out of your own wall that's right
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you